alright can you hear me over there in
the corner do I sound okay perfect um hi
my name is Ray and I'm a web dev and
I've learned a lot of things from
attending previous JSL lays in fact most
of all of the ten secrets to writing
perfect code that I'm going to tell you
tonight have previously been covered at
j SLA so here we go number one practice
practice practice practice just like
everything else in life that's
challenging and rewarding you need to
practice so you can practice with online
tools like notes cool or you can attend
to the upcoming node school or you can
do things like hacker ring you can also
work on side projects that's a great way
to practice and stretch your skill set
another great experience that makes you
learn is to break stuff you're just
laugh okay another thing that makes you
learn is to bring stuff because then you
get to practice putting it back together
so one thing that I'm practicing is
implementing the patterns of early
returns and sensible defaults okay this
slide is what not to do the slide is a
better example in the first slide if
you're given an argument value read the
function still performs an extra check
to see if you can match on the color
green we can do better by using an early
return when I call this function with
the parameter red we skip that second
conditional and we win with more
efficiency also you'll notice in this
first sample we would return an empty
string if we got an argument that wasn't
either red or green that's less than
ideal so in slide two will use a
sensible defaults and will return plan
which is more descriptive than an empty
string another technique that I'm
practicing is brevity for the sake of
clarity this function is actually
relatively short and sweet this one is
more okay number one done on 22 fine and
recognize patterns what's a pattern the
Google dictionary definition of a
pattern is a model or design that's used
as a guide patterns match a sample
design patterns are habits and practices
that other software devs have identified
as being effective you probably brushed
up on design patterns for job interviews
right am i right this is where you hear
about them okay the goal of finding
patterns is to stalk a mental store of
sample solutions to problems so that
when you encounter them you can use what
you know as a frame of reference so in
particular I want to mention to
JavaScript patterns modules and
microservices the characteristics of a
module using the module pattern are that
a module is independent it is
self-contained and it is hopefully
reusable so how you know module you'll
know when you when you see it because it
will probably use the keywords module
export yesous modules are the
fundamental building blocks of our world
like we call them the core modules
microservices value focused products and
services over more monolithic projects
these small contain units of
functionality are more composable and
are able to be reused in meaningful and
reactive ways we'll hear more about
modules and micro services as we explore
the other secrets so knowing the
patterns that we have here modules of
micro services they afford as ultimate
flexibility which brings us to our third
secret
rules rules outlined desired behaviors
and improve the likelihood of good
outcomes standards style guides and
coding conventions are types of rules
that can be as specific as the usage of
spacing or as high level as font and
color requirements like you might have
heard of and I currently use Jes
standard it might work so agreeing on
rules lessens the cognitive work of a
dub when they're reading the code some
general rules of thumb are to match new
additions to the surrounding code also
use meaningful names well what enforces
these rules hello elephant made of dryer
lint a litter is what enforces coding
Convention rules lynching is the process
of running a program to analyze code for
errors and rule exceptions linters help
keep code clean and readable which
brings us to secret number four you were
all waiting for this all month right
okay secret number four read code
personally no right some people this is
controversial personally if I'm curious
I'm likely to try to find something to
read an article with code samples is
great the first page of the github repo
okay possibly the example files and or
the index so I like to read code reading
code is an obvious way to learn syntax
and discover new approaches to problems
the goal of code reading is to observe
patterns and techniques and learn to
recognize when they're useful
ways I also might try to internalize
what I'm seeing is to visualize it by
drawing diagrams making flow charts or
writing stories or use cases so I would
read the package.json and the readme to
get a high level perspective and then
also if I was encountering a new project
that was actually a live production
project I would look for and scan that
configs because the configs might share
details about dependencies between
systems this is a joke you guys upcoming
a joke configs hold all the keys okay
thanks I really wanted to see your lap
okay on to number five functional
programming I'm also working on writing
functions without side effects functions
that are in mutable and stateless
functional programming is about
composability and using small pieces
that do one thing well all right these
two slides might help us conceptualize
this the turtles from XKCD are just one
of the multiple comics of turtles that
are probably the most eloquent
expression that helped me understand how
to think functionally so here's the code
pretend that this is the pile of turtles
the bottom turtle would say the next
turtle would stay ARF because those it
was called and then the cat turtle or
the de bird turtle would say tweet and
then the next one what would happen we
get back to the cat and that's as far as
we have in the picture but you could
imagine that the next turtle that could
be added would be a dog and then a bird
and then a cat and then a dog and then a
bird and you can basically build a
ladder
tall enough to paint a house by
imagining that each turtle is a
different function so can you see how
this chain of functions is a powerful
way to encapsulate logic in the same way
that products and services in an
ecosystem are meaningful together pure
functions are purposely simple building
blocks that can accomplish complicated
objectives in a really concise way for a
great deep dive see it carefully
composed logic of which of the JSL a
talk in the early part of 2015 okay fine
functional programming was really fun
next secrets comment and document all
right actually comments are a lie do not
believe everything you read in the
comments very probably they're a remnant
of an earlier dev possibly your past
self trying to figure stuff out do write
comments if you think it's going to help
you but if you write comments don't
insult yourself in the comments because
someone else might be reading them but
more importantly your future self is now
in charge of handling insults some of
the best commentary is found outside of
the code inside of version control with
get the commit history gives context
about who when and what was going on
when any given line was added or
modified so now we're beginning to talk
about documentation which is sometimes
an afterthought one way to get
documentation done is to consider
reusing the example that you're building
for development you need some way to
test your code no matter what you're
doing something so this can be a unit
test or an example that you could then
convert to the readme
unit tests are developers favorite type
of documentation and last month's JSL a
feature to talk on unit tests by Sarah
Rosh so if you want to learn more go
look that up if you're on a team and you
haven't got any documentation at all and
you are also using github a really easy
way to begin documenting is to use the
wiki feature i also want to mention
while we're talking about documentation
this interactive documentation that is
kind of bleep blending services and
documentation and that's a swagger tool
as something that's some out there so
there's three levels of documentation I
wanted to quickly cover on the method
level you should write down the expected
inputs and outputs on the module level
you should include usage examples and on
the product level for the project level
you want to include environment details
just like what you would want in a bug
report also instructions for how to get
a new instance up and running would you
believe it we're already up to the
seventh secret kiss dry or die all right
kiss you all know what that stands for
keep it simple silly that's not what you
thought it was going to say right but
really really simple takes practice
what's easier than copying code if you
copy and paste something that's pretty
simple it's pretty simple to do and
honestly that is also just fine
sometimes it's perfect and will be all
you ever need to do but if you find you
have to maintain duplicate code you're
probably going to end up doing a
refactor because the golden rule is die
or dry don't repeat yourself also known
as duplication is
the reasons for this are that one
version is more maintainable and it's
easier to reason about well abstracted
code so there is a tension between
what's easy and what's good the secret
is to get it working first then try and
get it right which may include
abstraction great number 8 data rules
okay mostly all systems exist to funnel
data some data flows are bi-directional
others aren't but everyone is unique the
group gathered here tonight has a large
breadth of experience with different
data sources we probably worked with
api's databases and real-time data
streams like with showcase at a previous
JSL a where we saw the custom jawbone
app consuming biometric data from the
device now I don't know if anyone here
would like to share but this is where I
was going to take comments if anybody
wanted to share data war stories now is
your chance anyone have a specially
interesting data story they'd like to
share all right I'll tell you mine
oh yes please tell me
Oh
he gave you a pile of crap this story
here which I don't know if everyone was
able to hear as well as I was he had set
out some code and it was returned with a
function called crap in it so um that's
pretty exciting kind of data experience
alright um another my harrowing tale of
data was actually not quite my own but
another dev told me how they forced
payment from a client by they had a
requirement to host the website on the
clients servers but they had no
requirement to host the database on the
clients servers so they didn't and then
they use the hostage database to force
the payment so what I'm driving at here
and which is leading into the next topic
is that your data is probably your most
valuable resource that brings up logging
you probably have volumes of valuable
log data and elk or maybe you don't but
if you do you're probably already
reaping the benefit of standardized logs
across products and services some of the
secrets to having good logs are to write
log server site at the beginning and end
of processes if it's the long running
process log the process duration also
you should log errors and write logs on
rights it's helpful when you're looking
at some generated file to be able to
refer back to the logs and see what
process made that right on the client
side oh this is the login gesture right
and that's not me I wish it was another
time I'm going to use this chainsaw for
a logs okay on the client side you
should leave commented out console logs
I know previously I had said that
comments are lies but this is the
exception console.log comments are great
they are my favorite kind of comment it
tells you here once was debugging but do
make sure if you leave these logs that
you comment the line out it's not polite
to leave messy trails in the inspector
all right and we have reached number 10
the end the secret here is to listen to
your audience identify stakeholders and
find out how they interact with the code
to learn their expectations we know that
there are three audiences for code like
get developers and the CPU there's
really only one audience for products
that's the users so to play nicely with
stakeholders use their terms and names
or if they have really bad names and
terms feed them good names in terms so
that you can develop a common vocabulary
before I close this listicle adventure I
want to make sure that we share a
sufficiently broad definition of
audience because we have a legal and
ethical requirement to give blind people
and other people who are differently
abled access to the world wild web if
you want to work on the consumer if you
do work on the consumer facing side of a
product the bureau of internet
accessibility offers a free
accessibility grading service but if you
want to make your website immediately
more accessible the top tip is to
include a skip navigation button before
the page nav to save screen readers the
monotony of reading the menu
and again so to wrap up these are the 10
no longer secret tips which I found
useful and trying to create perfectly
good code thank you very much
any questions for right
I'll put him up there for sure I didn't
do that yet but i will do that before i
go home yeah i'll put him in the slack
first great
all right enough array
this is awesome so like I said my name
is Aman I studied physics at University
of Cincinnati I now work for this
company data czar and before i get into
d3 and awesomeness of d3 i want to talk
to you guys about what we do a little
bit so we can get a little context so
days are is a research collaboration or
data collaboration platform we allow
people to upload data analyze that make
visualization stuff like that and share
it back to whoever uploaded the data so
you can kind of see context and I guess
it is not working